more people are heading outside to grab
a bite to eat as Nevada slowly reopens
from those koban 19 closures the city of
Las Vegas has introduced special outdoor
dining spaces downtown to help old
customers and local restaurants 8 news
now reporter Orko mana explains we felt
those the appropriate time to get
outside a near perfect night to dine out
downtown from 11:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m.
every day the city of Las Vegas closes
these half block sections in the
Downtown Arts District and near Fremont
Street placing tables and chairs for
people to enjoy a bite to eat
city staff wipe everything down in
between seedings to combat the corona
virus and Las Vegas are making the most
of the electric environment people are
being socially distant sort of by
themselves and on top of that with the
tables spaced out and the cleaning crew
being really attempted when people get
up and leave and everybody's just being
respectful of space it's the first time
since we've been out in a really long
time so it's actually the perfect time
the weather is great I feel very
comfortable and safe tonight the new
outdoor seating space is also a way to
help boost business at nearby
restaurants as many begin reopening
during phase one we're doing the the
half capacity table seating no bars
feeding until Phase two
while indoor seating at Esther's kitchen
is limited the assistant general manager
tells me the downtown dining arrangement
right outside their doors is encouraging
more customers to come by we've been
doing about the same numbers because
people are able to get that food to go
and bring it outside and kind of enjoy
the outside you know open space dining
the city says it's their way of offering
a helping hand I think the biggest
benefit really is for the businesses
that can open maybe earlier than they
thought they would be able to as Nevada
continues its phased reopening some say
this special seating will become a
terrific new tradition may become a
Saturday night happy hour type of
situation or camana
8 News now